i'm talking as a citizen
what can i do if i see something that's
wary
and something just doesn't look right
what what can we do
[Music]
to help because we got
you know 350 million people say 40
million people living in america
human traffickers it's not a big number
say it's in the thousands
but we got a lot of other adults that
are out there looking all this other
stuff what signs can we look for
and what can we do in that moment
you know to maybe potentially
help one girl that is going through the
mess that she's going with a trafficker
so the answer to that question actually
goes right back to the story you just
told
uh the you know people say well what
should we look for
uh well people will tell you that you
know you look for a girl with a crown
tattoo on her neck well that's that's
pretty old that's about
20 that that's about 20 years ago that
traffickers were doing what's the
problem what's the crime
they they put a crown they mark their
victims
um they used to mark them like on their
neck or on their face
until they figured out that it's pretty
easy for law enforcement to figure out
so they stopped doing that they still do
mark them but usually in a place that
you can't see
and but when you see something that just
doesn't make sense right especially when
it when it involves fear
we all know what fear looks like we
could see it in other people it's a
survival instinct uh that allowed
you know mankind to proliferate say hey
you know i'm afraid because there's a
lion over there
so we all know what it looks like so
when you see that you did exactly the
right thing which is you want to tell
the next level of authority that you can
right so in this case it was
you know it was the uh the crew at the
airline
if uh if if it's not the crew at the
airline it's going to be
the airport security it's going to be
a law enforcement officer it's going to
be calling your county sheriff
all of those things but then you get
this problem
with too much data because that law
enforcement officer who's a
human trafficking detective well that's
only one of their jobs
they're also working traffic two days a
week and they're also doing something
else because law enforcement is
undermanned
uh as much as anybody in the government
so that's where we come in
in that we provide technology software
so
it connects those cases across the
country so that those
those law enforcement officers can log
into our system and say all right
you know has any of the information that
this that this girl gave me or this guy
gave me has anybody
else in law enforcement seen this before
and so
they'll search it and oh yep sure enough
there's a guy there's a detective in
nebraska
all right let me call that detective in
nebraska and see see what's going on
right and so
so getting people to report things i
mean even if you don't
i mean you don't know it's a human
trafficking victim it could be
something completely different it could
be you know the the
girl's parents had died in a car crash
and this is an uncle she doesn't know
very well who was the last of kin who
now is taking
you know taking her on i mean you have
no idea but the point was that something
wasn't right
and so you told somebody and that is
exactly what the public needs to do
and err on the side of caution er right
just err on the side of caution like
this could
be a human trafficking problem it could
be a
kidnapping problem there was something
going on
so we need to tell somebody you know
again i'm not in your world but if i'm
in your world
you know i think speed is critical
right call to action is critical and
you know i understand research data all
of that but that's to hunt down the
trafficker right but when you're in an
opportunistic
moment you know um
there has to be because once once
they're gone they're gone your
opportunity's gone
you know how much does speed
play a role in catching traffickers when
you see an opportunity to execute
immediately meanwhile the law
enforcement agencies you're dealing with
maybe that's not at their top of their
priority
so what happens when you event intel do
they execute immediately it's like oh we
can't do it today we're so busy we'll do
it tomorrow
how does the level of speed to call to
action i'm gather the information i got
it how
how fast does execution happen executing
the
data that i got to go catch this guy
what have you noticed yourself
not near fast enough uh law enforcement
always wants to execute on it
immediately but great example is at the
super bowl
we had over 700 intelligence packages go
out
uh during a super bowl operation i if
you took every single law enforcement
officer
in the tampa era area and solely
dedicated them
to the human trafficking problem they
wouldn't have been able to get to the
bottom of it and and that's a
that's a very harsh reality of how big
this problem is
and it's gotten this big because we
never we never
took combating it seriously so now
uh we're at the super bowl my analysts
they know many human traffickers who
showed up at the super bowl
and then left the super bowl with their
girls well
quite frankly that sucks but
we have all that data and now we know
where they're going because they're
advertising
so we know where they're going to end up
the computers will let us know when they
settle
and then we can call law enforcement in
that area and say hey
these guys were just in the super bowl
and the reality is sometimes law
enforcement says hey we actually don't
have anybody who deals with human
trafficking
we don't want anything to do with that
um and
in which case you're like all right why
why do they say that though
because they're not funded for it all
right go to go to your local you i'm
sure you know some folks in law
enforcement
uh go to your police chief and say hey
um
show me show me the budgets for your
your narcotics unit for your gains unit
for your property crime unit and for
your
human trafficking unit and what you'll
find is that their gang's unit is fully
funded
narcotics unit is fully funded property
crime that touches commercial real
estate
which touches their donors the mayor's
donors so
guarantee you that's funded and many
times they'll tell you we actually don't
have a human trafficking unit
we have a detective who does something
else who
if a human trafficking case comes along
they go ahead and
and they deal with it so you
you obviously the idea of defunding the
police just even hurts us even more
because you need funding to be able to
execute on some of these things so
a question question for you on on
how many total traffickers are there not
victims but how many total traffickers
if you can estimate are there in america
today
i would estimate it around the man it'd
be
hard 25 to 50 000 mark
i'm sorry go ahead and and the way we
get that is again
we're talking illicit underground
commodities right elicit underground
networks
very very difficult to get good data on
that but the national center for missing
exploited children estimates that about
a hundred thousand
children a year children
enter the human trafficking market in
america
in america and these are american these
are american citizens this is not
lethal weapon and there's you know
chinese coming in over
shipping containers or the movie taken
um right this is this is uh this is our
sons and daughters that are being
targeted primarily
on internet platforms uh social media
uh gaming consoles by human traffickers
and groomed which is what they call it
into their
into their business enterprise i've not
asked you this before
but i'm asking you right now and
hopefully you will do this as a
valuetainer please
share this video text it to people hit
the thumbs up button
share it whatever way you can for other
people to see it for the algorithms to
be on our favor because this is not a
message about how you make millions how
you make billions how you become
successful
it's not entertainment this is purely
something that's about education and
awareness i'm asking you
share it with any parent that you know
and say just watch this video
get a paper and pen out you're going to
want to pay attention to this one here
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to
watch the entire interview and please
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye